welcome to best life 30 your 30-day
journey to creating the best life
possible for yourself you can just watch
this video or can sign up for free and
get the bonus companion worksheets that
go along with each video by checking the
link down in the description below
alright today is day 26 and we're gonna
learn how to think big yes what's next
what's next I gotta kid I'm not gonna
stay I'm not gonna stay I'm not I can't
do it man I can't do that what's next
give me something else what can't you do
I could do it I could do anything
I'm taking my amazon lottery winnings
and I'm converting them into reusable
rocket vehicles so that we can lower the
cost of access to space because right
now the price of admission to do the
interesting things in space is just too
high if I look at what Amazon was able
to do 20 years ago we didn't have to
build a transportation network it
already existed that heavy lifting was
in place we didn't have to build a
payment system that heavy lifting had
already been done it was the credit card
system we didn't have to build put a
computer at every desk that had already
been done - mostly for playing games by
the way and so on so all the pieces of
heavy lifting were already in place 20
years ago and that's why as with a
million dollars I could start this
company today you know and then there
are even better examples on the internet
over the last 20 years you know Facebook
started in a dorm room I guarantee you
two kids cannot build a giant space
company in their dorm room it's
impossible but I want to create the
heavy lift
infrastructure kind of do the hard part
so that a future the future generation
two kids in a dorm room will be able to
create a giant space company society and
folks like me put an unfair pressure on
people to have a vision yeah right and I
think that's true we're not all Steve
Jobs and we don't all have big
world-changing visions to your point I
do believe however you can find a vision
right in other words it doesn't have to
be yours it can be someone else's we
found Martin Luther King we found
Mahatma Gandhi we found Steve Jobs we
found Richard Branson whoever you Elan
musk the visionaries and people go
I love his vision so organize your
business around that right you don't
have to have a vision but I do believe
you have to find one people find it in
religion you know you follow whatever
you follow right you you become a
follower of so you can say I believe
insane airs as yours I believe in that
and we're organizing our our company
around helping to build that world yeah
so I don't believe you have to have one
I do believe you have to find one Yeah
right and it doesn't have to always
operate at a macro level it absolutely
can operate at a micro level right it
can be the way you raise your family the
way you treat your friends how do you
come with this idea actually sometime
they're pushing the human limit you are
always pushing the human limit why well
when I think about what's what
technology solution is necessary in
order to achieve the particular goal and
then try to make as much progress in
that direction as possible I think the
being a multi-planet species being out
there among the stars is important for
the long-term survival of humanity and
that's one reason kind of like life
insurance or life collectively life as
we know it but then the part that I find
personally most motivating is that it
creates a sense of adventure and it
makes people excited about the future
now if you consider two futures one
where we are forever can
until eventually something terrible
happens or another future where we are
out there on many planets maybe even
going beyond the solar system I think
that second version is incredibly
exciting and inspiring and they need to
be reasons to get up in the morning you
know life can't just be about solving
problems otherwise what's the point it's
gotta be things that people find
inspiring and make life worth living and
I want people to understand this dream
big but get small wins don't ya I'm
saying dream big but get the small wins
and no smart never forget here in John
Elway's speak once you know John Elway
was like you know I became great by
being good over a long period of time
you know and so for me it was alright
get he's leaving she's going to college
if I can get my GED that's that's all I
need to focus on right now is let me get
the GED and here's the thing I never
realized by having a girlfriend it was
like I'm not dating anybody selling dope
I'm not dating anybody that's you know
violent you know I'm not dating nobody's
carrying a gun so for me those were
words yeah so for me it was like I
didn't even know about being with her it
stopped me from doing some of the stuff
that had I not had a purpose I probably
would have been doing what my boys was
doing because I was with them I just
wasn't doing what they were doing you
know so the GED was the first win then I
ended up following her going to college
my first college was Oakland went to a
very small school in Alabama but then
after I finished that and I was speaking
at the time and so now universities are
like University of Cincinnati saumui
University of Louisville Michigan State
so Michigan State can say hey all these
guys like you but we won't accord you
like we want you to come get a degree
and eventually work for the university
so I'm thinking high school dropout you
know I got a four-year degree I go to
Michigan State like I can make my mama
try to get I'm from Detroit so it's you
avail or it's Michigan State and so I'm
like you know I can reverse this to my
little sister went to U of M so if I go
to your Michigan State my mom that's
like house money y'all say that's like
mom could be proud of me again because
you know of course leaving home you know
we get into it you know it's a point
where my mom was kind of discouraged
like I didn't raise you like this you
know so to go to Michigan State get a
master's degree it's like y'all can make
mama proud and then when she came to the
gradual
I decided I might as well get the PhD
you know this let's just finish it up
bring her back one more time and some of
the pain that I caused her I'm sure
another degree is only gonna make it at
you know much more so I just say may I
start with the small wins thanks was
profitable from the first month that I
was in business and I I'm in of the
belief system for me in my journey to
start small think big and scale fast and
a lot of people want to start big and
think big and oftentimes get ahead of
themselves and and that can end wildly
successfully but it can also cause a lot
of problems and you dilute yourself down
a lot and you know then you have a lot
of other people you're answering to so
that just was the journey that I took
you know I mean is I started it with
five grand I've never had any outside
funding and whatever money I made from
selling Spanx I just put back into the
business I love that start small think
big what is it you're really after and
is it after what you are you after
enough for yourself are you are you
limiting yourself based on your current
competencies a lot of people do that
they narrow their vision or their
ambition for tomorrow based on what they
can do today or who they are today
without realizing they can develop their
mastery their skills their competency
their knowledge their experience without
realizing they can become a better
person they can live into their highest
self they can live into the type of
person who could accomplish those goals
who could have those things so never
limit your ambitions based on your
current competencies never limit
yourself today based on your current
inadequacies because those can be
irrelevant
tomorrow the main thing is to have aim
in life to have your own aim to have
your own ambitions not the ambition
somebody told you you should have where
someone told you you're supposed to be
after because that's how we all get on
sort of you know sometimes a corporate
treadmill or we get on those things
where we just start trying to live a
life that's not even our
because we're just going with everybody
but ambition liberates that your
individual ambition who you want to
become what you want to do what you want
to contribute and the highest forms of
all ambition usually come down to your
creative expression your contribution
and your connection with others that
created expression what is it you want
to create in this world and I mean get
your hands dirty doing you know not just
create some PowerPoint once in a while
for some corporate thing but something
real and meaningful that you consider
art for yourself whatever that is even
if it is a PowerPoint presentation right
but to do something that you find
artistic and meaningful that's our human
drive for creative expression then what
about contribution what's your ambition
to give and to serve greatly for others
what do you really want to give back or
give to others what is it
and what about connection you know the
ultimate ambition and aim to have I
think for a lot of people is their
relationships to operate and have a love
that knows no bounds I mean a love that
is extraordinary that it is amazing you
can't improve your relationship with
your family or your spouse or those that
you serve unless you have in some sense
about you that desire to love or give or
connect more so today get clear what is
it you want and is it big enough for
yourself not limiting yourself based off
your inadequacies or your competencies
but based on what you truly desire last
challenge take whatever that is that you
come up with and 10x it take it by 10
times what would be 10 times that
ambition not just because it's silly I
know I know it's kind of silly but to
take that ambition that you initially
have which is usually what we usually
want is an impulse based on who we are
today and I just challenge people don't
think bigger for yourself because you
are immense
you are magnificent you are powerful
beyond your current understandings so
break through that another
challenge your brain to think even
bigger for yourself even it's just as an
activity to break the bounds of your
current beliefs and behaviors you
deserve something extraordinary in your
life but at first you have to want it I
think that as you know right now the
computer industry is in the tank
personal computers big computers
everything and it's difficult it's a
difficult time but I'm sure that Henry
Ford had a few bad quarters back in the
1920s and the automobile had a sort of
historical imperative it had the minute
it was invented a sequence of events had
to happen the same is true with the
personal computer there is a tremendous
momentum behind this and I think that
this year maybe a delay this year we may
look back and say well 1985 was a slow
year but there is such momentum behind
this that it will happen it will
permeate and change forever our
educational processes and my hope again
is that not too many generations of
students will pass through before this
happens it will happen within 20 years
it probably will happen within 10 years
but it could happen within five years I
am going back to the United States this
weekend and then about two weeks from
today I'll be in the Soviet Union for
the first time in Moscow because one of
my dreams has been to sell Macintosh's
in the Soviet Union
and one of the highest the genom agendas
on Maya priority is to is to get them
starting to think about exactly the same
thing so maybe six months or a year year
and a half from now we can have some
Soviet schools here at our your a
consortium meeting Jeff it's worth about
150 billion dollars the founder of
Amazon this is what he looked like
almost twenty years ago twenty years ago
they laughed at him twenty years ago he
wasn't worth $20,000
let alone 150 billion now he's got to
come a company roughly speaking around a
trillion dollars little less maybe 150
billion less because the sell on the
market etc but they laughed it and he
had an idea he had a dream like him I
had a dream about 35 years ago I am the
first person on the planet
it took an option for something he did
not own on a major stock exchange I'm
gonna say okay I don't own that book
right I paid him a dollar on the
national TV five dollars for that book I
hear from now I took an option I took
that but not only eat it and I sold it
on the new york stock exchange for 150
million bucks that's what i did and that
was the beginning of my quantum leap to
be a great leader to inspire other
people here's what i believe in that you
must have something that it's bigger
than yourself in order to inspire people
in order to enroll people into your
vision example if you talk to your
employee talk to your team member and
you say hey you know what this is why
we're doing this so that i could make
enough money so that I could retire or
so that I could build this business so
that I could be living the 10 hour
we core 12 hour work week to be a
lifestyle entrepreneur see that doesn't
inspire anybody because it's all about
me me me me me so to be a great leader
to inspire other people you kind of have
vision that is so big there's so
compelling that other people want to be
part of them right it's like imagine you
are the captain of this ship and you're
saying hey this is where we're going
we're going to this island and it's
going to be great and we are going to to
have all these great things when we get
there and that's like wow you know
people look at that say yeah I want to
be part of that but I want you I want to
join this journey I want it I want to
join alongside it and be alongside with
you and maybe there's some obstacles
there will always be challenges there
will be waves in the ocean but that's
okay I want to join you and help you to
fight along and be alongside with you
going through this journey so I believe
very much that leader needs to think
about what is your mission
think big my mind still running through
all the conversations I had with Arnold
Schwarzenegger last night in his kitchen
talk to him for about an hour's one of
the greatest conversations I've ever had
and that's one of the takeaways I think
big you know he told me he said he
always thought big he said don't worry
about failure so much time how far can
you really fall we're all only a few
feet from the ground and I was thinking
mentors you know he told me about his
mentor reg Park his first mentor but I
thought that's what's wrong in the world
that's why it's so easy to feel lost who
do we have guiding our way you know you
got to go out you have to find people
you have to find people who have done it
before who can shorten the path who can
keep you from failure he told me he said
don't fail too much one of the reasons
he doesn't procrastinate and can think
big he said is because he he at 20 years
old won mr. Olympia so he said he got
used to success and he tasted success
and so you know make sure you find some
little wins in life they'll always lose
it's a myth that you
we want to learn from mistakes what do
you learn from mistakes they don't have
to be yours though people in the modern
world with all this convenience we have
the next thing you know all you're doing
is just sitting around not accomplishing
anything you know go out conquer the
world conquer your fears
think big it's all I could think you
know he's a big dude strong but his life
was big made some mistakes made a lot
great attempts and successes see this is
the problem I had as a young salesman
dude I was like okay imma make a degree
in a year it didn't worth it like like
like if I make 80 grand a year as a
salesman I'm making $7,000 a month and I
live in Miami you're not going to do it
changes nothing the opportunity has to
change your life significantly enough
that you're willing to read study dive
in right you add a zero to that right
there you had a zero to that 80 now I'm
willing to learn every human being is
like this by the way every human being
on this planet maybe I'm wrong tell me
if I'm wrong comment please I had a zero
to that you're gonna do stuff that you
wouldn't have done just a moment but
okay if I can show you how to how to go
from 80,000 to 800,000 all sudden your
creativity you like I think I just met
van Gogh goddamn I got some Madonna
coming out of my butt okay whoa whoa
whoa I got music in my head like leg
ding ding ding ding you like you because
why man because yeah maybe the glass
underneath my feet don't hurt so bad
right because why because the goal is
big enough most people do not have goals
that will change their lives therefore
they cannot lean into the opportunity
hard enough for those of you who own
businesses you need to create rings in
your business ok so that Natalie can see
hey man I can go outside this these I
can go outside these rings and there's
more opportunity out here for financial
freedom or she stays
here and she didn't resent me she
resents her because I keep throwing them
out here I'm like hey there's a twenty
thousand dollar product you can sell
right here there's a five thousand
dollar product you can get benefit from
here oh by the way there's a million
dollars out here if you want to there's
a lot of things I want to do I always
wanted to be a director I think as well
I have so many girls come out to me and
tell me that they want to be models
which is fine it's not a bad thing I
just think there's so much to do I just
went to a wonderful talk about genetic
engineering and neuroscience and this
man who is giving the talk explained
this is ten thousand kids is from the
age of seven to thirteen who are doing
neuroscience they do these competitions
and wonderful things and they're doing
things in neuroscience which haven't
been which weren't done by him until he
was like thirty like how quickly things
like that are changing and but they're
not there is an awareness sport it's
cool stuff like that like that sounds
way cooler to me them being a model but
like no one really knows about it and I
just think there are just so many things
I always say to cosmic just dream just
dream bigger go for president just keep
going up astronauts I don't know now
I've got a really special bonus clip
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the best live
thirty questions of the day it's not
enough to just watch a video you have to
do something about it so pull out your
worksheets and if you don't have the
worksheets you can get them for free
using the link in the description below
here we go question number one what is
your bigger vision for yourself number
two what are your limits that you need
to push and number three what's the
champions mindset that you need to
develop and if you're doing the best
life thirty challenge with me I want to
celebrate you give me a hashtag best
live thirty down in the comments below
the secret to getting everything that
you want out of life is to think big and
act small think big have a huge dream
create a vision for yourself that
excites you that you want to make happen
and then act small don't let the big
dream be so big that it becomes so scary
and you never start find the smallest
possible way to just get started
think big act small otherwise your
dreams will
exactly that I recently had a guy pop
into my Instagram live who was a fitness
coach and he's building his success up
and doing one-on-one training fitness
and helping people get results and he
said Evan how do I go bigger how do I
build my brand how do I get people to
know me I said of just my my pocket my
community said well you have to create
content you got to be a thought leader
you got to be an expert I got to see you
doing what you're doing how often are
you making videos I said well I don't
know making them once a week okay great
dude how often do you go to the gym how
often do you work out how often you care
about your nutrition
I said well every day like you have to
take this same approach to your business
to making content to being a thought
leader said are you in shape and at the
time he's shirtless and then he said
yeah I'm in shape and he he pans down
and you see his abs and then back to his
face he's got the smile on his face like
I love it man you put that into your
daily routine you're working out and
eating right as part of your daily
routine he said yeah but it's so hard to
to go off and make videos every day
what are your clients saying to you
about working out and eating properly
that it's so hard dude it's the same
excuses you've already figured this out
in one area of your life the problem is
you're not being consistent in the other
areas that if you want to blow up and be
a thought leader and get a lot of
traction and attention to views you need
to get good at the thing you don't
become great at anything doing it once a
week if you believe that you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
Michael Jordan wasn't practicing
basketball once a week you just will
never get great at it you have all of
this untapped potential all of this
abilities that go off to make a huge
impact but we never see it because
you're doing it once a week you just
will never get good at it you'll never
get good enough at the thing if you're
only doing it once a week
so he says what do I do great you put
into your routine you already know how
to do this you just have done it for
something else all of you you've already
been consistent on something now make
this next business goal part of your
daily routine it's thinking big and
acting small most people think big and
have this big vision of where they could
go it's amazing I believe in your vision
I love you I want to see you go up and
crush that huge goal I think you can do
it but then show me you calendar where
you
taking the action because most people
are spending too much time just thinking
thinking thinking planning planning
planning you gotta actually get going
and doing it daily consistent small
action one video for my friend who's
running his gym now one video is not
gonna do anything one video one small
act is not going to do anything it's the
accumulation of the daily videos that
are coming out the daily content the
daily improvements that's where you
start to build momentum the biggest
thing that's missing from most of your
ideas is momentum because you're
thinking big but you're not acting small
so how do you get started how do you
build momentum I'm gonna give you a
3-step process that I think will help
step number one is apply the two percent
difference the two percent difference
means as soon as you get a goal in mind
most things that we want to do most
people what we what we do is we think of
planning that step number one for most
people as planning no don't plant your
first step after you come up with an
idea is to act planning is important
it's just not your first step
most people will plan their way to 100%
right plan to how I'm gonna accomplish
my goal and then they wake up tomorrow
they've lost the boldness they lost the
confidence and they say I'm not gonna do
that I can't do that there's a momentum
and then the dream dies on the table the
first step is momentum the first step is
action the first step is figuring out
the first 2% that's it 2% don't plan to
100% instead act on the first 2% why is
it so important because when you're
feeling bold when you're feeling
confident when you get that idea it's
flowing through you right you're in that
energy zone you want to use that energy
to build momentum using that best energy
to go into planning and then you wake up
tomorrow a different person you've lost
it all where if you use that energy into
action into momentum then tomorrow
you're gonna wake up and see oh I've
already built some momentum it's easier
to keep the ball rolling the hardest
step is the first one so push build that
first step when you're feeling the
energy so as soon as you get in your
next idea apply the 2% difference your
first step is to act
step number two is thinking about your
big wine little wine I'm a big believer
that you have a big mission a big vision
a big thing that you're trying to
accomplish and it's inspiring why do you
do the work that you do because you're
trying to make the world a better place
that's what we as entrepreneurs want to
do that that mission is inspiring it's
amazing it gets you up out of bed but
sometimes it's too big
sometimes you think well Who am I to go
off and do that sometimes you think well
other people should do that who have
more money and more funding the more
skills and more knowledge - more
resources I can whom I I can't do that
and so on some days the Big Y is
actually too big when you're trying to
motivate yourself to get going and take
action the big wine might be the
greatest thing of all time but sometimes
it's too big that's where you need to
little Y big Y and a little Y when the
Big Y seems too big you use the little Y
what's the little why the little Y is
the small daily little comments that you
get the little pieces of feedback that
you get for me the little Y is people
who who read my book trying to find a
copy people who read my book and then a
message me for people who leave comments
on my youtube channel like you guys who
comment down below we read them for
people who DM me on Instagram that's a
little why it's knowing that the work
that I do has an impact because a
one-off comment doesn't mean a lot in
the grand scheme of things but I know
that I hit one person however many views
this video gets the people who comment
are weighed less than the number of
views right that's always the case and
sometimes the views don't make sense I
mean the idea that I get a couple
hundred thousand views a day on my
youtube channel doesn't make sense what
does that even mean I don't know but
seeing somebody comment to say this
video had a big impact on my life
thanks to this video I'm taking action
in my business today that's that's deep
and meaningful
that's the little one so find the little
wide version in your business you may
not think that you're capable of
accomplishing some big thing every day
but knowing that you help one person and
give the motivation to get up and do it
again tomorrow and again tomorrow and
again tomorrow Big Y little Y and set
number three's expect to suck at the
start this is this is what really holds
people back you start something you
expect to be great at it it doesn't work
out and then you quit why do you expect
to be great at it it's the first time
you're doing it from my buddy who called
in to the Instagram live show he was
shredded with his abs and he's gonna
make good video his first video is gonna
suck right if it doesn't suck he should
have started years ago his first video
is going to suck that's the best and as
kids we know this as kids we try new
things and we fail at everything we get
out ha ha ha laugh it off and keep going
but as adults we try something new and
then we fail and then we stop and we
never do it again
then you will never learn anything new
aren't you're gonna be stuck inside your
box the rest of your life
expect to suck at the beginning it's
okay it's normal doesn't mean you suck
as a human just means you know the skill
set yeah how do you get the skill set
you practice you get better you learn
you study you put in the wraps and so
whatever it is that you're trying to
take on yes you've got this big goal big
ambitions big dreams I think you can get
there amazing the first start is right
now today what are you gonna do and in
that starting expect nothing to happen
expect just to suck everywhere you make
your first video it's gonna be brutal
you can write the first page of your
book you're gonna be embarrassed by it
you should be embarrassed by it it's
okay it's great the quality is gonna
suck the results will suck but what you
want to tie your self-worth to is the
effort that you did it that you got
started and if you do that every day
be proud of your effort every day I
guarantee you're gonna get results if
you want to join the best life 30
challenge click the link right here
below me or if you want more videos on
how to think big check the playlist
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it